analyst states I guess it's really just
starting just this month with the
opening of the Whitney Biennial I've
been really interested in animals since
I was quite young and spend entire
summers at the zoo where I grew up in
Minneapolis so I feel like on some level
I've been waiting for years and years
and years to do something with animals
or about animals and I think that's
probably true of everyone's work I think
your work really grows out of really
deeply felt work rose out of interests
that have probably been with you your
whole life in some way in you know you
have your whole life to constantly kind
of have those kind of pour out it reveal
themselves in different ways so when I
was invited to be a part of the Whitney
Biennial dates specifically invited me
to do a project for the front of the
museum the entry in the sculpture Court
and I was up in the woods and New
Hampshire doing a residency at McDowell
colony at the time sitting in my cabin
alone every day and first getting really
excited about the opportunity and then
of course render wondering right away
like what the hell am I gonna do and I
think their first assumption was that I
would do some sort of garden project and
of course that doesn't make any sense in
March in New York and then you know
typically when I'm invited to do a
project I just go right away to what I'm
obsessed with at that moment and at that
time it was just animals I've been
thinking a lot about animals and and
actually on top of this I've been
invited to do about six or seven Museum
Commission's this year one after the
other which is part of the reason I'm
traveling all year just going from place
to place doing these projects so as a
way to make sense of all these various
invitations and to to to start this new
start this new series of projects this
year I decided to make them all animal
estates projects so basically there's
nine or eight editions of animal estates
that will be happening in in different
cities around the world each one
similar in a way to the model of edible
estates in that each one will be very
responsive to the place that I'm in even
though in some cases I will have never
been to that city before I start working
the project it's a very kind of narrow
kind of research to go into right away
and find local experts but basically the
goal of the project is to make homes for
animals that have either been displaced
in in the city where I'm working or are
good cohabitants for humans in the
cities that I'll be in so for example in
in New York at the Whitney Museum the
real the real switch in that project
where I began to understand it is when I
found out about this project called the
mannahatta project by Eric Sanderson
he's been researching for 10 years the
history of the island of Manhattan 400
years ago when the European settlers
first arrived what it looked like
developing a really clear picture of it
naming exactly all the flora and fauna
that were here in each region so he can
tell you what Times Square looked like
you know what the or in the case of the
Whitney Museum there was a stream and it
was likely a site of beavers and beavers
ponds so with the Whitney Museum I
decided to make a home homes for 12
animals that used to live on the site of
the museum
400 years ago so in that way I'm making
fully-functioning homes for animals that
will idealistic Lee in some way welcomed
them back to a place that they've been
kicked out of essentially so it's really
anchored by a beaver dam in the
courtyard and then a large eagle's nest
up in the entry portico and then a whole
bunch of little homes for other animals
each project that I do and always the
first thing I think about is what can I
do here that I can't do anywhere else
what's uniquely possible in this
location and that drives almost
everything that I do so in the case of
the the sculpture court at the Whitney
Biennial that's huge it's such a
particular place it's it's first of all
the museum's designed by Marcel Breuer
who's who's been had a huge influence on
me I grew up around one of his buildings
in Minnesota so there's this building
that almost really feels sacred to me
when you cross you cross this bridge to
get into the museum and your aunt you're
you're going from the world of daily
banal life to almost this sort of
spiritual sacred sort of experience with
art that is made very clear by this
bridge across this moat really the
sculpture Court so and it's also very
similar to the front lawn this moment
where the private sacred space of the
home meets the public kind of banal
space of the street so it's that
threshold that I've been working with in
a lot of ways lately anyway so I really
wanted to create a project that somehow
bridged the two had the museum come out
to meet the people on the street and
conversely had the street come and meet
the people in the museum
so these animal homes and the stories of
them become a way to bridge those two
and to have this conversation between
what we think about is the kind of
preciousness of the sculpture a
sculptural object meeting kind of the
junky quality of this stuff we have in
the street like lampposts and newspaper
dispensers and benches and things like
that so you know the owl nest box up in
the post at the corner of 75th and
Madison and one hand is just this junkie
piece of wood that anyone can
at home over a weekend but at the same
time it's part of museum installation
that has all you know this aura around
it so I like the idea of taking these
animal homes and raising them up to the
level of sculpture but at the same time
reducing them to down to the this these
elements of daily life I'm really
interested in in what the public and
what the audience thinks about the work
and how they experience it it's it's
part of the project really it's not just
a a secondary thing that you make
something and then you hope people like
it it's really that experience of people
interacting with it is this part of the
whole way the idea for the work was
generated I I created a project where
there's the animal homes in the sunken
sculpture Court and then around the
perimeter at the sidewalk there's 12
plaques one for each 12 animals with the
animal in first person telling you about
their home so the project is really
designed to be experienced from the
street from the sidewalk not necessarily
by people who are going into the museum
so I really viewed it as a project for
anyone who's passing by that can get
drawn into the story by these these
plaques and these stories by these
animals so I had the benefit of starting
installation about two or three weeks
before anyone else did and it's already
been installed now in place for a few
weeks so I've been really interested to
see how people have experienced it and
it's really nice to sit down in the
sculpture court look up and see these
faces pop up read the plaques look
around you know there's the the Bobcat
plaque so they look down look for the
Bobcat home and then they're looking for
the Bobcat to see if he's there but
there the project is really generated
for that sort of experience with by the
audience and I'm all
not very aware of it